when did you start the company and what
was the goal of story this company and
then even taking us back what did you do
at LinkedIn well the company is about
four and a half years old the team came
from LinkedIn and we actually created an
open-source project there internally
great and so we you know you were saying
we kind of started as engineers but I
guess for these open-source projects
you're kind of the the product in the
marketing and the engineer yeah
explain that with open-source how does
it open source project work for somebody
who's heard the word open source but
doesn't understand how an open source
project is called the project as opposed
to a company right yeah yeah you know I
mean it's it's kind of a methodology for
making software where people just
contribute bits and it's done out in the
open and you can kind of see how it
works and pick apart the bits of it and
you know it kinda became pretty
mainstream and a lot of these big tech
companies so a lot of the internal
infrastructure at LinkedIn was built
that way and this is Apache yeah yeah so
the the system we built is called Apache
Kafka right Apache is the web server
yeah everybody knows Apache is is a web
server and then a whole foundation for
these open-source projects and so they
kind of help you know govern these
communities they contribute to them
Connor a stupid question but for people
who don't know who decides what goes
into the software
you know if there's 20 people
contributing to this open-source project
you created at LinkedIn who gets to
decide if LinkedIn and Microsoft and
Google are all contributing to it and
somebody says I don't want to add that
at Microsoft's like no you have to add
it that's is that resolved it's one of
the fascinating things about these
open-source projects the first thing
they have to do is you know pick a
governance model it's like picking your
constitution or something is it going to
be
democracy is it going to be dictatorship
right benevolent dictator the Apache
projects are kind of a you know it's
sort of representative democracy where
there's some set of people who are kind
of going through and improving all the
changes and helping set direciton
and is it the first people who sign up
are the most important you know it's
it's your project it's based on
contribution so people who come and and
contribute and stick around do it
and and so that works pretty well that
kind of incentivizes people to try and
do something useful so you were making
this Apache who was the name of the
project Kafka
Kafka Yeah right like the writer yeah
see a surrealist or yeah yeah kinda and
you picked that yeah yeah you're a fan
yeah a little bit
you know we had we had a we had a you
know for these internal projects they
always have goofy names so we had Rory
Potter characters we had a database
named Baltimore for a while yeah and
then then we switched to writers so what
was this project Kafka that you built
that in the Apache framework what was
the goal of that at LinkedIn yeah you
know like the transition LinkedIn was
going through was you know kind of
moving off you know running big Oracle
databases and then moving to this world
of like big distributed systems that
have data all around the world kind of
scale on bunches of servers and so you
know we were doing a bunch of things to
try and make that transition and one of
the things we thought you needed was
something that would work off of streams
of data and so we thought like look you
could look you could think of all the
clicks on a social network and all the
updates to people's profiles and all the
emails you could see that as some stream
of changes and you could build all kinds
of things around that and so we built
you know a system that did that and we
spent about five years you know turning
that into something that kind of scales
around the world with trillions of
events flowing through it in real time
and then as that was open sourced it got
really popular mostly just in Silicon
Valley so all the you know the ubers and
Pinterest Sand Airbnb zall chose this
architecture that was kind of built
around these real-time streams and so
way for somebody to think about this is
hey it used to be you have a database of
say books and Amazon every book ever
made and every day they put 500 new
books in yeah but when you start
thinking about tracking real-time data
say on Twitter you might have somebody
who uses Twitter every day
like comment retweet and tweet 500 times
a day themselves yeah and then you might
have
ten million of those people doing it all
day long or a hundred million and now
you've got five billion or 50 billion
behaviors moments being added to a
database yeah that's exactly right so
like in some sense traditional databases
you would hear the phrase data
warehousing and it's kind of like in the
Indiana Jones you know that big
warehouse yeah sure the company it is
yeah it's all full of data and you might
go ask it some question but the the
answer is out of date by the time you
get it right but for you know for these
much more real-time you know consumer
sites that kind of doesn't cut it you're
not like producing updates for your
users at the end of the day or you're
doing something continuously and so so
it does work much more like Twitter
where there's some feud of all the
changes that are kind of flying at you
and you kind of process it as it occurs
and this required a different database
architecture yeah than the one that came
before it explained the paradigms of
these databases and we all hear about
Oracle they've built this ginormous you
know trillion dollar or business or
whatever it is in terms of revenue over
the last decade around the concept of
these you know huge databases but the
open source systems came in and
challenged them or replace them or
evolved them how do you look at it
versus what people used to do
III think there's like a huge transition
happening right now where you know there
was traditional databases like Oracle
with the emergence of these kind of
consumer tech startups you had people
that were like using data in a
completely different way and they kind
of built their own databases which was
what LinkedIn was doing and Facebook was
doing and Google was doing why did they
make their own was it a function of what
you know it's a bunch of things like one
the whole company is kind of built in
software in a way that was pretty niche
you know maybe 20 years ago and is now
becoming very mainstream and all kinda
thing from grocery stores to car
companies would think about themselves
that way so they just had a lot more
data it was much more deeply intertwined
with how they served customers and then
the scale is a lot a lot larger is just
a lot more data about more things and
was it also did also have to do with the
arduous nature of maybe getting through
the Oracle
sales process to buy and spend a million
dollars on a license to build a database
when you're doing some social network
that has tons of data but no tons of
data but maybe you have no revenue yet
yeah you know I maybe that's part of it
the but but I think a lot of the big
change came not from that because you
know they were able to hold on to that
for a long time and what's actually kind
of chipped away at it has been you know
these totally different ways you know
totally different requirements totally
different product something that runs
across a fleet of servers in the cloud
you know it's just built completely
differently for different use cases and
so of course then people like these
open-source software components they
love these cloud services where you can
just buy what you need and pay for what
you use and you're not locked in forever
and so that that's been a huge part of
it but I think without this kind of
change in how people think about data I
don't know I don't think you would have
gotten gotten in there with just a
better sales model and so you have this
open source project that everybody
spending fitting from and then you
decide confluent will become a
for-profit company that provides what
around this open source project yeah you
know we were so we were looking at what
was happening we thought look we have
you know huge adoption you know
basically in a 50 mile radius of where
we are like all the silicon die tech
companies are using this everybody else
is interested but like they need
something that's much more of a product
and plugs into all the system say they
want something that can be like a cloud
service or that can be you know easy to
manage in their data centers they don't
adopt technology the same way that the
kind of tech companies do right and and
so if we really want to make this
something real we got to really turn it
into a real product and take it out into
the world right and so that's what we do
so we we you know we provide a version
of this it's you know secure that you
know scales elastically that you can run
across data centers and then we you know
help companies actually get that going
and run it and then we offer it as a you
know as a service in the cloud so you
can just kind of you know pay for what
you use and get it without having to do
any of the work yourself